when I was a kid all I heard was weed
was the gateway drug I disagree I think
it's cereal all that Sugar Cyril's
getting kids high way younger than weed
kids even look like addicts when they
wake up they're like damn I need a bowl
I mean diabetes obesity we pumped that
[__] in the kids early that's why half
the cereals are named after drugs smacks
all right
Special K
Golden Grahams are already dealing in
grams I don't know like you go down the
cereal aisle in Australia or Europe it's
all Health Food heart healthy whole
grain fiber you go down to cereal out in
America it's like a [__] Acid Trip
all right I mean it's just bright colors
and wacky cartoon characters every
cereal mascot looks like a cracked out
attic you got a paranoid leprechaun and
a jacked up rabbit stealing [__] from
kids yeah Tony the Tigers clearly coked
up he's like they're great yeah how
about that wide-eyed toucan hey kids
follow your nose